for those of you looking to save a buck
tomorrow for valentine's day bianca
holman shares some of the great deals
you can score
from buy one get one free to special
treats companies are ready to celebrate
valentine's day if you start your
morning with a cup of coffee starbucks
orders can get 50 percent off for up to
10 dollars off on ubereats with a promo
code v-day 50. what's better than a
chicken sandwich two for one that's the
deal at popeye's on february 14th
properties near and on the strip like
virgin hotels and the cosmopolitan of
las vegas have several restaurants
offering special prefix menus along with
the romantic ambiance and if you're
looking for a fun activity there's the
ethel m's cactus valentine's light
display or you can impress your new bay
with a las vegas night flight and foodie
tour with maverick helicopters
with the day of love on a monday there
are adult shows like magic mike and
fantasy with special viewings
whatever you choose to celebrate quality
time with your partner is what matters
most bianca holmen live local now